Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt. Ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner, der
Leiter der Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung,
derzeit der Kommandant der Garde in Wien. In
unserem heutigen Video wollen wir ganz kurz
die letzten elf Monate betrachten des Konflikts
in der Ukraine, des Angriffs Russlands
auf die Ukraine. Wir wollen uns ansehen:
die ersten Erfahrungen, die wir bereits jetzt
ableiten können und mögliche Herausforderungen,
die wir in diesem Konflikt in den
nächsten Monaten noch sehen werden.
Beginnen wir ganz kurz zu Verortung mit dem
Koordinatensystem, in dem meine Aussagen
getroffen werden. Dazu muss man verstehen, dass
wir hier tatsächlich in diesem Konflikt bereits
eine Dimension haben, die über mehrere Domänen
hinweggeht. Wir haben die Elemente Luft, Maritim,
Land und natürlich auch nicht zu vergessen den
Weltraum, den Cyberraum und den Informationsraum.
Also alle Ableitungen, die wir treffen,
befinden oder finden in diesem Raum statt.
Wir unterscheiden zuerst zwischen der taktischen,
der operativen und der strategischen Ebene. Die
taktische Ebene bezeichnet Elemente wie zum
Beispiel Waffensysteme, die verschiedene
Fähigkeiten haben, wie zum Beispiel dieses
amerikanische HIMARS-System. Die operative
Ebene bezeichnet Offensiven wie es die Offensiven
waren von ukrainischer Seite bei Kiew bei Charkiw
oder auch bei Cherson - oder auch der Angriff von
Russland zu Beginn des Krieges. Die strategische
Ebene ist aber jene Ebene, die entscheidet, ob
sie einen Konflikt über lange Zeit führen können
oder nicht. Hier in diesem Fall der Angriff der
russischen Seite auf die kritische Infrastruktur
der Ukraine. Beginnen wir ganz kurz zuerst mit
der taktischen Ebene. Was man hier feststellen
kann ist, dass die Idee der russischen Seite aus
den Erfahrungen von 2014, mit bataillonstaktischen
Gruppen einzumarschieren, so nicht funktioniert
hat. Warum? die bataillonstaktische Gruppe hat
offensichtlich vor allem was den Anteil der
Infanterie betrifft eine Unterlegenheit, die
sich gerächt hat beim Angriff auf die ukrainische
Seite. Die ukrainische Seite hingegen hat ganz
entscheidend verstanden, dass durch den Einsatz
zum Beispiel von präziser Artillerie, aber vor
allem auch durch den Einsatz leichte Elemente,
es möglich ist, dieser Struktur der russischen
angreifenden Kräfte etwas entgegenzusetzen. Das
heißt, das entscheidende auf taktischer Ebene ist
es, dass die Taktiken, Techniken und auch die
Maßnahmen, die man im Gefecht getroffen hat,
entscheidend sind für den Erfolg, so wie wir
ihn dann gesehen haben von ukrainischer Seite am
Beginn des Konflikts. Das Zweite ist die operative
Ebene - die Ebene, auf der verschiedene Offensiven
durchgeführt worden sind. Hier ist er ganz klar
festzustellen, dass die ukrainische Seite nach
dem ab Erfolg bei Kiew diese Erfolge auch weiter
fortsetzen konnte - und zwar bei den Offensiven
bei Charkiw, aber auch in weiterer Folge beim
Rückzug der russischen Truppen aus Cherson auf
die andere Flussseite. Trotzdem muss man auch
feststellen, dass auch die russische Seite im
Verlauf der letzten 11 Monate Erfolge verzeichnen
konnte. Das war die Einnahme der Stadt Mariupol
nach schweren und heftigen Gefechten und sehr viel
zivilen Opfern, aber auch die Kesselschlacht bei
Sjewjerodonezk und Lyssytschansk im Sommer oder
jetzt die Situation bei Soledar-Bachmut, wo die
ukrainische Seite sehr unter Druck steht und man
erkennen kann, dass möglicherweise die russische
Art der Einsatzführung, nämlich dieser massive
Artillerie-Einsatz, ihnen zum Erfolg verhilft.Wir
nehmen aus dieser Darstellung mit, dass beide
Seiten durch eine hohe Flexibilität immer wieder
in der Lage waren, sich auf die verschiedenen
Situationen einzustellen und erfolgreich zu sein.
Die nächste Ebene ist die strategische
Ebene, jene Ebene, die entscheidend ist,
wenn es darum geht, einen Konflikt über lange
Zeit zu führen. Hier war es der Fall, dass
die russische Seite erkannt hat, dass durch den
Einsatz der Luftstreitkräfte mit weitreichenden
Waffensystemen wie ballistischen Raketen, Cruise
Missiles, aber auch Drohnen es möglich ist,
die Achillesferse der Ukraine anzugreifen und
das ist die kritische Infrastruktur. Das heißt,
obwohl paradoxerweise die ukrainische Seite sehr
erfolgreich auf operativer Ebene ist, hat sie
die Herausforderung, dass die russische Seite
auf strategischer Ebene immer wieder versucht,
die kritische Infrastruktur - das ist natürlich
die Stromversorgung der Ukraine - anzugreifen
und das ist sehr erfolgreich.Wir haben es auch
gesehen, am Beginn des Krieges, dass die russische
Luftwaffe sehr wohl in der Lage war, ihre
Ziele umzusetzen. Das Ergebnis dieser Angriffe
auf strategischer Ebene ist, dass wenn man es an
diesen Bildern betrachtet, die Stromversorgung der
Ukraine immer mehr getroffen wird und die Ukraine
die große Herausforderung hat, mit dem Einsatz der
eigenen Fliegerabwehr auf dieser strategischen
Ebene dem etwas entgegenzusetzen. Hier geht
es also vor allem um die Ausdauer,
diesen Konflikt weiterführen zu können.
Springen wir nun auf die Fähigkeiten.
Die Fähigkeiten, die entscheidend sind,
dass Streitkräfte in einem Konflikt Erfolge
oder Misserfolge erzielen, diese entsprechenden
Fähigkeiten sind hier abgebildet. Nur gemeinsam
und ineinandergreifend ist es möglich, durch
Einsatz dieser Fähigkeiten tatsächlich Erfolge zu
erzielen. Beginnen wir mit der ersten Fähigkeit:
der Vorbereitung. Hier hat man gesehen, dass
der Einmarsch der russischen Seite auf Annahmen
basiert, die sich dann in weiterer Folge nicht als
umsetzbar herausgestellt haben. Ein gutes Beispiel
ist die Schlacht um Kiew, wo in den ersten
48 Stunden das Gefecht zugunsten der Ukraine
entschieden worden ist. Die Ukraine hat damals den
Fluss Irpin aufgestaut, die Brücken gesprengt und
durch den Einsatz von Artillerie die angreifenden
russischen Elemente nachhaltig geschlagen.
Auf der anderen Seite: hervorragend dargestellt
für die ukrainische Seite hat sich vor allem
der Einsatz von kleineren Einheiten und
der Spezialkräfte, denn diese haben vor
allem in Nadelstich-Taktik versucht, den Russen
Schaden zuzufügen und das auch sehr erfolgreich
umgesetzt. Das heißt, hier ganz klar der Vorteil
einer entsprechenden vorausschauenden Planun,g
der hier entscheidend für die ukrainische
Seite war: die Vorbereitung auf diesen Krieg.
Sehen wir uns nun den zweiten Begriff
an: "Project", also die Fähigkeit,
Kräfte zu projizieren. Hier ist interessant
festzustellen, dass in diesen elf Monaten
trotz dem missglückten Angriff der russischen
Seite, es den Russen immer wieder gelungen ist,
sich neu auf Situationen einzustellen. Wir
haben das also hier gerade auch am Beispiel
von Kiew noch einmal, wo wir sie sehen können,
dass die Russen innerhalb von wenigen Tagen,
von knapp zwei Wochen, fast 50.000 bis 60.000
Soldaten aus dem Raum Kiew abgezogen haben - im
Eisenbahntransport 1.000 km in den Donbass
verlegt haben und dort dann versucht haben,
in einer neuen Phase noch einmal anzusetzen. Auf
der anderen Seite hat es die Ukraine geschafft,
die Waffenlieferungen, die aus ganz Europa
und auch aus den USA eingetroffen sind,
vor allem in Polen, in das Land zu bringen und
hier schnell und rasch zu den kämpfenden Verbänden
vorzubringen, wo sie in der Lage waren, diesen
Abwehrkampf gegen die Russen weiter zu führen
bzw. auch sich vorzubereiten auf eine weitere
Offensive. Das heißt, entscheidend war hier,
das Momentum aufrecht zu halten, um das Nähren
der Kräfte weiter sicherstellen zu können.
Sehen wir uns nun die Fähigkeit Angriff an. Hier
ist ganz entscheidend, dass wir erkennen können,
dass in diesen elf Monaten vor allem
die Geschwindigkeit das entscheidende
Element war. Die Geschwindigkeit vor allem beim
Einsatz von Waffensystemen. Wir haben erkannt,
dass die ukrainische Seite, was den Einsatz
ihrer Artillerie betroffen hat, sehr schnell
reagieren konnte und Ziele bekämpfen konnte,
während die russische Seite immer noch sehr
zentralistisch Feuer-Anforderungen durchführen
konnte. Auf der ukrainischen Seite war es möglich,
Feueranforderungen innerhalb von wenigen Minuten
tatsächlich umzusetzen, während auf der russischen
Seite Ziele, die man erkannt hatte, bei dem
Eintreffen des Feuerkommandos - also bei dem
Eintreffen der Granaten - oft nicht mehr
vorhanden waren und man kann gut erkennen,
dass gerade auch in diesem Konflikt diese
Fähigkeit entscheidend ist, aufgrund des
Einsatzes von massiven Artilleriewaffen, dies
von beiden Seiten hier eingesetzt werden. Sehen
wir uns als Nächstes den Begriff Schutz an - also
die Möglichkeit, die eigenen Kräfte zu schützen.
Am Ende der zweiten Phase, wo also die russische
Seite vor allem im Donbass die ukrainische Seite
in Lyssytschansk und Sjewjerodonezk bekämpft hat,
war es so, dass durch die Lieferung von speziellen
Waffensystemen - und das war das HIMARS-System
aus den USA, 20 Stück die hier geliefert worden
sind - es möglich war, vor allem Munitionsdepots
der russischen Seite anzugreifen. Innerhalb von
wenigen Wochen wurden hier massive Zerstörungen
durchgeführt und es hat eine Zeit gedauert,
bis die russische Seite in der Lage war, sich
hier wieder anzupassen. Einerseits durch ein
Verlegen dieser massiven Munitionslager in
viele einzelne Teillager, aber andererseits
auch durch den Schutz von Fliegerabwehrsystemen,
wie zum Beispiel diesem System "Pantsir", hat es
wiederum möglich gemacht, diese HIMARS-Raketen der
ukrainischen Seite zu bekämpfen. Dem musste etwas
entgegengesetzt werden und das war der Einsatz von
diesen Antiradar-Raketen aus den USA, die wiederum
diese Pantsir-Systeme bekämpft haben, damit
das HIMARS-System wieder in der Lage war, diese
Waffenlager zu bekämpfen. Das heißt, man sieht,
dass immer wieder der Versuch da war, aus einer
symmetrischen Situation in eine asymmetrische
überzugehen. Wichtig ist aber zu verstehen, dass
der Schutz der Ressourcen notwendig ist, um diesen
Krieg weiter voranzutreiben und führen zu können.
Sehen wir uns nun die Durchhaltefähigkeit
an und zwar am Beispiel der Kräfte,
vor allem auch jetzt noch an dem Beispiel
mit dem Munitionseinsatz. Wir wissen,
dass die russische Armee eine gewisse Anzahl von
Kräften verfügbar hatte. Es gibt unterschiedliche
Zahlen dazu, als Beispiel nehmen wir 10.000
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, Kampfschützenpanzer,
und ca 1.500 Panzer, die sie in den Einsatz
gebracht haben. Tatsächlich sind diese Zahlen
noch wesentlich höher. Man geht davon aus, dass
Russland um die 10.000 Panzer verfügbar hat. Mit
der Instandsetzung wäre es sicher möglich, ca.
3.000 bis 3.500 für einen Einsatz am Gefechtsfeld
verfügbar zu machen. Auf der anderen Seite,
die ukrainische Seite hat am Beginn des Krieges
ebenfalls signifikante Mengen verfügbar gehabt.
Man nimmt an, dass die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
die quantitativ stärksten Streitkräfte Europas
waren. Über 2.000 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge.
Kampfschützenpanzer, über 1.000 Panzer, die hier
verfügbar waren. Diese Kräfte wurden verwendet,
um in der ersten Phase die angreifenden russischen
Kräfte abzunutzen. Das heißt, Russland hat sehr
hohe Verluste erlitten, aber auch die Ukraine
hat sehr hohe Verluste erlitten - bis im Juni
aus ukrainischen Quellen ca. die Hälfte
ihres Equipments der Landstreitkräfte.
Die Problematik besteht aber auch gerade
in der Munition und im Munitionseinsatz,
am Beispiel Artilleriemunition gezeigt. Man
nimmt an, dass Russland ca. 17 Millionen Schuss
Artillerie-Munition verfügbar hatte, von denen
in den letzten elf Monaten 7 Millionen verbraucht
worden sind. Die eigenen Produktionskapazitäten
sind ca 3,4 Millionen. Das heißt, man hat noch
10 Millionen plus die Produktion dieses
Jahres und ist in der Lage, diesen Krieg
auch länger zu führen. Auf der anderen Seite hat
die Ukraine ihre Munition relativ rasch verbraucht
und hier ist das Ziel das Umstellen auf die
westlichen Kaliber wie das Kaliber 155 mm,
um auch die Ukraine weiter versorgen zu können.
Das, was an Gerät bereits geliefert worden ist,
das hat die Ukraine in die Lage versetz,t dann
im Sommer die Offensiven bei Cherson und Charkiw
durchzuführen. Wenn man jetzt aber genau hinhört
dann hört man, dass der ukrainische Generalstab
ganz klar gesagt hat: Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir
wieder in die Offensive gehen, dann brauche ich
noch einmal eine dritte Lieferung. Ich brauche
noch einmal 300 Panzer, ich brauche nochmal
600 bis 700 Kampfschützenpanzer, ich brauche
noch einmal 500 Artilleriesysteme. Das heißt,
die ukrainischen Landstreitkräfte müssen zum
dritten Mal neu offensivfähig gemacht werden.
Sehen wir uns nun den Begriff "Inform"
an. Inform bedeutet vor allem Aufklärung.
Aufklärung ist ganz entscheidend und zwar
bereits von Beginn des Krieges bis jetzt.
Das erste Entscheidende zu verstehen ist,
dass mit Einsatz der russischen Kräfte auf
dem ukrainischen Territorium, also mit Angriff
der Russischen Föderation auf die Ukraine,
es zu massiven Unterstützungsmaßnahmen gekommen
ist des Westens. Diese Maßnahmen haben vor allem
auch den Aufklärungsbereich betroffen -
durch Satellitenaufklärung, durch Signal
Intelligence und andere Möglichkeiten wie auch
zum Beispiel Human Intelligence war es möglich,
ein sehr genaues und exaktes Lagebild über die
russische Einsatzführung zu bekommen. Dieses
Lagebild besteht bis heute. Es war auch der
Grund warum es gelungen ist, für die Ukraine,
doch einige Generäle auf russischer Seite
zu töten. Und man hat auch erkennen können,
dass vor allem der massive Einsatz von Drohnen,
vor allem auf unterster Ebene, man nimmt an,
dass zu jedem Tag des Konflikts zwischen
4.000 und 5000 Drohnen unterschiedlicher
Größen im Einsatz sind, es möglich ist, das
eigene Lagebild entscheidend zu verstärken.
Ein Teil dieser Drohnen wird unter anderem auch
eingesetzt zur Eigenaufklärung, um ein Bild
davon zu bekommen, ob man in der Lage ist, seine
Kräfte getarnt und geschützt abzustellen oder ob
der Gegner mit seinen Drohnen in der Lage ist,
diese aufzuklären. Das heißt, Drohnen spielen
in diesem Konflikt eine sehr, sehr große Rolle,
nicht nur auf unterster Ebene zur Aufklärung,
sondern auch bis auf die obere Ebene inklusive der
Bewaffnung, wie wir es auch hier im Einsatz sehen.
Sehen wir uns nun als weiteres Beispiel "Consult,
Command, Control" an - also die Führungsfähigkeit.
Hier gibt es zwei Elemente, die entscheidend sind,
zu verstehen: Das eine ist die Art und Weise der
Führung. Das heißt, die Fähigkeit vor allem von
unterster Ebene bis nach oben vor allem im Sinne
der Auftragstaktik zu führen. Auftragstaktik
heißt, dass der Untergegebene versteht, was
von ihm gefordert wird und danach handelt. Und er
braucht die Kommunikation dazu. Hier muss man ganz
klar feststellen, dass vor allem durch den Einsatz
des Starlink-Systems die Ukraine bis heute in der
Lage ist, in einer Art und Weise zu kommunizieren,
die es für die russische Seite sehr schwer macht,
diese zu stören. Und dass der Einsatz dieser
kleinen Einheiten, die im Sinne des Auftrages
denken, dazu geführt hat, dass viele der
Offensiven sehr erfolgreich durchgeführt
werden konnten. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir
auf der russischen Seite eine sehr zentralistische
Führung, die Zeit braucht, um Entscheidungen
von oben bis nach unten zu kommunizieren. Wenn
diese Entscheidungen getroffen sind, ist es
aber auch für die russische Seite möglich,
Erfolge zu erzielen. Man hat es sehr gut gesehen
auch bei Cherson. Hier wurde die schmerzhafte
Entscheidung vorgeschlagen, offensichtlich an
Putin und auch genehmigt, der Rücknahme der Kräfte
auf die andere Seite. Hier ist bemerkenswert, dass
diese 30.000 Mann und ca. 2.500 Fahrzeuge ohne
dass von ukrainischer Seite ein Schuss abgegeben
worden ist, sich auf die andere Seite zurückziehen
konnten, was ein bisschen den Vergleich historisch
mit Dünkirchen bemüht. Denn damals 1940 war es
auch möglich für die britische Seite, Kräfte nach
Großbritannien überzusetzen, die dann in weiterer
Folge des Krieges verfügbar waren. Und auch hier
sehen wir jetzt, dass diese 30.000 Mann nach dem
Abzug quasi verfügbar waren, einerseits am Südufer
aber auch in weiterer Folge bei Melitopol oder auch
natürlich bei den Kämpfen im Donbass, die sich
wieder zugespitzt haben. Sie werden sich nun die
Frage stellen, woher diese Bewertungen stammen,
die wir in den roten Textfeldern dargestellt
haben. Interessant ist, dass in den letzten elf
Monaten bereits Einiges an Berichten erschienen
ist, die sich kritisch mit den Erfahrungen
dieses Konflikts auseinandersetzen. Erfahrungen,
die wichtig sind für die Zukunft von
Streitkräften. Ich möchte jetzt zwei
als Beispiel nennen, beides Ausarbeitungen des
"Royal United Services Institute for Defence and
Security Studies". Die eine Ausarbeitung
befasst sich mit jenen Beobachtungen,
die gemacht worden sind in den ersten Monaten des
Krieges, betreffend den Einmarsch der russischen
Streitkräfte in der Ukraine. Was ist für die
russische Seite gut gelaufen, was ist für die
russische Seite schlecht gelaufen? Es gibt eine
zweite Ausarbeitung, die sich befasst mit den
ersten Erfahrungen und Bewertungen den Einsatz
der russischen Luftwaffe betreffend. Wo war die
russische Luftwaffe erfolgreich und wo hat sie bis
heute es nicht geschafft, durchschlagende Erfolge
zu erzielen? Ich habe aber auch zitiert den
ukrainischen Generalstabschef, den amerikanischen
Generalstabschef und als Beispiel den Leiter
des estnischen Militärnachrichtendienstes.
General Saluschnyj hat vor kurzem gesagt: Wenn die
ukrainische Armee wieder in die Offensive gehen
soll, bevor die russische Seite sich eingegraben
hat, dann brauche ich neuerlich 300 Panzer,
600 bis 700 Kampfschützenpanzer und 500
Artilleriesysteme. Das heißt, die ukrainischen
Landstreitkräfte müssen zum dritten Mal mit
Kräften ausgestattet werden, um wieder offensiv zu
werden. Der US-Generalstabschef hat nach dem Abzug
der russischen Streitkräfte von Cherson gesagt,
dass beide Seiten 100.000 Mann an Toten und
Verwundeten erlitten haben. Er war der erste,
der das so in dieser Form gesagt hat. Er hat
aber auch gesagt, dass der Sieg der Ukraine bei
Cherson die Möglichkeit für Verhandlungen
öffnen sollte. Dem wurde widersprochen
und an letzter Stelle möchte ich nennen den
Leiter des estnischen Militärnachrichtendienstes,
der sehr klar herunterdekliniert hat, dass die
Möglichkeit der Ressourcen-Nutzung von russischer
Seite noch sehr hoch ist. Einerseits was die
Munitionsausstattung betrifft, aber auch die
Verfügbarkeit von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen. Und
ich möchte aus diesen zwei von mir genannten
Dokumenten ein Zitat herausnehmen, das im
Prinzip im Kern eine wesentliche Aussage trifft,
denn es ist wichtig zu verstehen, dass wenn
wir verstehen wollen, wie der Konflikt sich
tatsächlich entwickelt, wo wir stehen und
wo auch für uns Ableitungen zu treffen sind,
es nichts bringt, die russische Seite als
inkompetent und nicht einsatzfähig zu bezeichnen,
sondern dass wir anerkennen müssen, dass es
Erfolge gegeben hat, die wichtig sind zum
Verstehen, um uns auf eine mögliche weitere
Eskalation des Konfliktes vorzubereiten.
Ich gebe Ihnen auch ein Beispiel: Der britische
Nachrichtendienst versorgt uns immer wieder mit
nachrichtendienstlichen Informationen und
hier haben wir zwei Beispiele gegenüber
gelegt. Einmal vom Juni des letzten Jahres und
einmal vom Dezember. Hier können wir lesen,
dass der Einsatz der russischen Luftwaffe und
der Einsatz der Präzisionsmarschflugkörper
offensichtlich keinen Effekt erzielt. Hier im
Dezember sieht die Situation ganz anders aus,
hier kann man bereits erkennen, dass der Einsatz
dieser Marschflugkörper, ballistischen Raketen
und Drohnen sehr wohl einen Effekt erzielt
- nämlich auf dieser strategischen Ebene, wo
Russland immer noch festlegen kann, wann, wo und
in welchem Umfang es die ukrainische Seite trifft,
die immer noch das Problem hat der mangelhaft
vorhandenen Fliegerabwehr und das Problem der
immer zunehmenden Zerstörung der kritischen
Infrastruktur. Wir sehen das auch in einem
Zitat des Präsidenten, der im November gesagt
hat, dass bis jetzt über 4.700 ballistische
Raketen, Marschflugkörper und Drohnen gegen sein
Land eingesetzt worden sind. Mittlerweile ist die
Zahl bei 5.000, das ist eine Zahl, die es noch
nie so in der Kriegsgeschichte gab und viele
dieser Raketen treffen ihre Ziele. Das haben wir
spätestens seit dem 10. Oktober gesehen, wo es
zu diesen massiven Schädigungen der kritischen
Infrastruktur kommt und wo klar ist, dass die
ukrainische Seite Flugabwehrsysteme braucht, um
dem etwas entgegenzusetzen - aber nicht ein oder
zwei Batterien, sondern viele, viele mehr. Während
im Westen Rätselraten über die Einsatzfähigkeit
der russischen Streitkräfte herrscht, versucht die
russische Seite ganz gezielt durch eine Vielzahl
von Formaten entsprechend diese Narrative
so zu füttern, dass klar ist, dass das,
was die russische Armee sich vorgenommen hat,
sie auch tatsächlich umsetzen können. Und hier
gibt es eine ganze Reihe von offensiv aber auch
im Hintergrund agierenden Nachrichtenformaten,
vor allem in den sozialen Netzwerken, die
hier versuchen, gezielt die Informationen
weiterzugeben, dass der Eindruck entsteht, dass
hier sehr große Erfolge erzielt werden und das ist
natürlich genau die Propaganda, der die russische
Seite, die russische Bevölkerung unterworfen ist.
Wenn wir uns jetzt am Ende fragen, was fehlt
noch ein Ausstattung und Gerät bzw. wie kann
der Konflikt weiter verlaufen, so ist ganz
interessant, dass mehrere Fragen, die ich
kurz stelle, Ihnen einen Aufschluss darüber geben
können. Wir haben bereits gesehen den Einsatz des
amerikanischen HIMARS-Sytemes. Hier war es so, dass
die Amerikaner 20 Stück geliefert haben und 18
Stück für die nächsten zwei Jahre zugesagt haben.
Die nächsten wurden bereits in Kürze in Aussicht
gestellt. Die ukrainische Seite hat aber 50 bis
100 gefordert - das ist aus militärischer Sicht auch
legitim, denn nur das kann einen tatsächlichen
Effekt erzielen. Die zweite Frage, die wir uns
stellen müssen: Warum wurden bis jetzt keine
Kampfflugzeuge geliefert? Keine Kampfflugzeuge
vom Typ F-16 oder Erdkampfflugzeuge vom Typ A-10? Auch das
würde zu einer möglichen Eskalation offensichtlich
führen. Das Gleiche gilt für die Lieferung von
weitreichenden Waffensystemen. Wir haben zwar
einige Einsätze gesehen von weitreichenden
Waffen z.B. auf der Krim bei Saky aber auch z.B. auf
Engels oder in der Tiefe Russlands oder z.B. auf Sewastopol,  aber es gab immer
noch keine Lieferung dieser ATACMS.  Bei den
Fliegerabwehrsystemen hat jetzt langsam
begonnen, die Lieferungen dahingehend zu entwickeln,
dass IRIS-T-Systeme aber auch PATRIOT-Systeme
geliefert worden sind, aber auch hier ist die Menge
nach wie vor gering, um nachhaltig einen Abwehrerfolg
zu erzielen. Und das letzte Thema das sehr intensiv
diskutiert wird, ist natürlich die Lieferung von
Panzern und hier ist es so, dass momentan zugesagt
sind 50 Stück Kampfschützenpanzer Bradley, 40 Stück
Marder, Großbritannien hat in Aussicht gestellt,
zehn Kampfpanzer vom Typ Challenger und Finnland
und Polen haben ebenfalls in Aussicht gestellt
die Lieferung von Leopard-Panzern. Wenn man diese
Zahlen zusammenrechnet und vergleicht mit
den Forderungen von General Saluschnyj,  dann
sieht man ganz klar die Ablage. General Saluschnyj
fordert 300 Panzer - in Aussicht gestellt ist jetzt die Lieferung
von 30. Er fordert sechs- bis siebenhundert Kampfschützenpanzer,
zusammengezählt ist das die Zahl von ca.
90 und die Artillerie-Systeme, die ebenfalls
zu liefern sind, sind in diesen Lieferungen noch gar
nicht eingeschlossen. Aber, wenn die Ukraine weiter in die Offensive gehen will, dann braucht
sie natürlich diese Ausstattung, um hier gegen die
russische Seite angreifen zu können, vor allem
wenn man bedenkt, dass die russische Seite sich
jetzt in den letzten Wochen und Monaten in dem von
ihnen in Besitz genommenen Gelände eingegraben
hat durch Panzerigel, durch Sperrmaßnahmen, durch
Minenfelder, etc. Und
dass zusätzliche Kräfte herangeführt werden.
Wenn wir uns jetzt noch mal kurz diese drei Ebenen
vor Augen führen, die taktische, die operative und
die strategische, so sind folgende Entwicklungen
interessant: Die taktische Ebene hat immer noch
die Herausforderung, dass beide Seiten in einem
Kräfteverhältnis stehen. Auf der einen Seite die
russische Seite, die mit zu geringen Kräften
begonnen hat, die aber durch das Nachführen
von Reservisten langsam beginnt, die ukrainische
Seite in der Verfügbarkeit von Kräften zu überholen.
Auf der anderen Seite die Verfügbarkeit
von Fahrzeugen, wie Panzern,  Kampfschützenpanzern oder Artillerie-Systemen. Wo wir immer noch
erkennen können, dass es ein Delta gibt, zwischen
dem, was die Ukraine verfügbar hat dem, was Russland
verfügbar hat und Russland beginnt, immer mehr
Ressourcen verfügbar zu machen und neue Kräfte
heranzuführen. Wir haben noch immer in der Woche
ca. ein, zwei Militärzüge, die herangebracht werden,
während die Waffenlieferungen aus dem Westen aus
Europa, aus der USA relativ spärlich von Statten
gehen. Entscheidende Durchbrüche, die Lieferung
von hunderten Systemen gleichzeitig,
haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Wenn wir uns die operative Ebene ansehen, dann ist
die Frage, was soll mit diesem Waffen passieren?
Und hier ist es die Absicht der ukrainischen
Seite, zwei Korps aufzustellen, also Formationen
mit mehreren 10.000 Mann. Einmal im Raum Poltawa
und einmal bei Dnipro in Saporischschja. Diese beiden
Korps würden sich für folgende Einsatzführungen
aus operativer Sicht eignen: Einmal nach einer
Bereitstellung der Angriff in Richtung Donbas,
mit dem Ziel, die Versorgungslinien in den Donbas
abzuschneiden oder andererseits aus Saporischschja heraus
antretend in Richtung Süden die Landlinie,
die Landverbindung zu unterbrechen, mit einem
Angriff über Melitopol in Kombination mit einem neuerlichen
Versuch der Zerstörung oder Beschädigung der Brücke
über die Straße von Kertsch. Dieser Ansatz wäre der
Erfolgversprechende, denn es würde somit gelingen,
die russischen Kräfte auf der Krim in Cherson und Saporischschja
abzuschneiden und die russische
Seite hätte ganz andere Herausforderungen
zu bestehen als zurzeit das Nähren der Angriffe in Bachmut oder auch im Donbas.
Das strategische Element ist ebenfalls nicht zu
unterschätzen und hier erkennen wir, dass aufgrund
der Angriffe der kritischen Infrastruktur
es zweierlei  Arten der Maßnahmen gib. Auf der
einen Seite versucht die Ukraine durch defensive
Maßnahmen, durch Fliegerabwehr, diesen Angriffen
entsprechend etwas entgegenzusetzen und wir
erkennen auch, dass die Abschusszahlen der
einfliegenden iranischen Drohnen, aber auch
der einfliegenden Marschflugkörper immer mehr zunehmen.
Auf der anderen Seite versucht man aber auch
offensiv, jene Räume zu treffen, von denen aus
dieser Angriffe geflogen werden,  also der
Einsatzraum der russischen strategischen
Bomber tief in Russland selbst oder zum
Beispiel die Basen der russischen Schwarzmeerflotte in Sevastopol, diese Schiffe,
von denen aus diese Marschflugkörper gestartet werden
die dann Ziele in der Ukraine treffen.
Abschließend muss man feststellen, dass
das was sich in den ersten Monaten des
Konflikts herauskristallisiert hat, nämlich der
Umstand, dass dieser Krieg als Abnutzungskrieg
geführt wird, sich immer mehr tatsächlich der
Wahrheit entsprechend darstellt. Wir sehen das
hier an diesem Bild: Dieses Bild zeigt eine von
Granattrichtern zerfurchte Fläche bei Bachmut
übersät von getöteten russischen Angehörigen der
Söldnergruppe Wagner. Man erkennt hier
eine Art der Kriegsführung, die wir in dieser Form
nicht mehr für möglich gehalten haben, eine Art der
Kriegsführung, die an die Schlachtfelder des Ersten
Weltkrieges von Verdun oder auch an den Isonzo
erinnert und diese Art der Kriegsführung
ist natürlich für beide Konfliktparteien
verheerend. Wir sehen das hier an diesem Zitat - auf
der einen Seite hat die russische Seite immer noch
die Herausforderung, dass sie über zu wenig Infanterie
verfügt, um einen Entscheidung herbeizuführen. Auf
der anderen Seite sind
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte gefordert, die von
ihnen im Besitz habenden Geländeteile so lange
wie möglich zu verteidigen, um zu verhindern, dass die
russische Seite diese einnimmt, was dazu führt, dass
es zum Teil schwerste Verluste gibt, so wie wir sie
gesehen haben bei Lysychansk, Sjewjerodonezk
oder jetzt bei Soledar oder auch Bachmut.
Die Frage ist nun am Ende, wer wird den längeren
Atem haben in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten und
wir sehen, dass die Unterstützung der Ukraine
aus militärischer Sicht vor allem von den USA
stattfindet, während die europäischen
Arsenale zunehmend unter Druck kommen.
Auf der anderen Seite sehen wir, dass die
russische Rüstungsindustrie bereits im 3-
Schichtbetrieb arbeitet und auch zunehmend
modernere Systeme an der Front eingesetzt
werden. Trotz der hohen Verlustraten, die
einen aus westlicher Sicht unglaublich
erscheinen, ist es der russischen Seite immer
noch möglich, die Angriffsfähigkeit dahingehend
zu nähren, dass sie in der Lage sind, die von ihnen
im Besitz genommenen Geländeteile zu halten.
Damit bin ich am Ende meiner Präsentation, die
Botschaft, die ich Ihnen mitgeben kann ist, dass
dieser Konflikt noch länger dauern wird und
wir dürfen nicht nur auf die Ukraine und auf
Russland sehen, sondern wir müssen auch bedenken,
dass Kräfte im Hintergrund eine Rolle spielen,
also China, der Iran oder vielleicht auch sogar
Indien. Oder auf der anderen Seite natürlich die
USA, die Europäische Union oder andere signifikante
Unterstützer. Man kann sich den Konflikt auch
vorstellen wie einen Boxkampf - eine Runde nach der
anderen findet statt. Die ukrainische Seite hat
mehrere Runden nach Punkten gewonnen, aber es hat
bis jetzt noch kein k.o. gegeben. Damit bin ich am
Ende meiner Ausführungen, ich sage herzlichen
Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.